of a for his part after the caucuses
drops out of the campaign and makes a
big announcement as of this moment we
are going to suspend this presidential
campaign and this is going to have to
be there's no path for me to be the next
president absent things that we don't
want to see happen in this country and
I'm also making the decision that this
has to be an America First candidate in
that white house
as I've said since the beginning there
are two America First candidates in this
race and earlier tonight I called Donald
Trump to tell him that I congratulate
him on his victory and now going forward
he will have my full endorsement for the
presidency and I think we're going to do
the right thing for this country so if a
drops out endorses Trump I think the
smart move for him